in the heart of the panamanian jungle
lies a chocolate factory it's owned by
mavis ortiz
and is very special because the
chocolate it creates
is made from organic sustainable cocoa
farmed under fair conditions
miami i want to get the word out that
chocolate isn't candy
coco is a plant that confers health and
well-being
ortiz gets the raw cocoa for her
chocolate from a nearby village
in solidardisco in panama's boccaz del
toro province
the inhabitants have preserved an
ancient tradition
in accordance with the practice of their
indigenous forebears
the nobe they cultivate cocoa in a
particularly green
and sustainable manner jungle clearing
and plantations are nowhere to be seen
nor do they use pesticides
instead they grow cocoa in the middle of
the jungles
we harvest some trees and use them to
build our
timber houses
we grow various crops for food
and of course the cocoa that we sell
commercially
we use an agroforestry system we don't
create
monoculture cocoa plantations that's
just not in keeping with our tradition
cocoa specialist mavis ortiz was also
convinced by the merits of their natural
cultivation method she decided to set up
her
artisanal chocolate factory right next
door five years ago
she wanted to use the best possible
organic cocoa
so she decided to work with the cocoa
farmers from solidardisco
only their traditional cultivated cocoa
grown in the heart of the jungle
meets her requirements
the soil is protected by leaves it's
healthier for people because no
chemicals are used
cocoa plants have a good yield and their
cultivation is environmentally friendly
when they get the right amount of shade
neither too much nor too little
beneficial
besides cocoa rare flora also grow among
the trees
as well as plants used for medicinal and
ritual purposes by the nobe
the country's largest indigenous people
but industrial cocoa cultivation is
increasingly squeezing out the old
methods
agroforestry graduate mavis ortiz would
like to help stop that
that's why she regularly holds training
sessions for cocoa farmers
so they can further refine their
cultivation methods
and improve the quality of the beans
[Music]
would like to know how to choose the
best branch for grafting
ortiz is particularly keen to support
the female cocoa farmers
she wants to provide them with an income
of their own so they're not solely
dependent on their men
folk that's why she pays 60 percent
above the going rate hey muchas
i would like their work in cocoa farming
and chocolate production to be more
highly regarded
that goes down well with the women
it's important for us women to get
organized
if we join together we'll reap the
benefits
we look after our children we feed them
and educate them
and this would allow us to earn more
money to give us more opportunities
ortiz processes the raw cocoa on her
nearby finger
first it's left to ferment for several
days
and then it has to dry
the beans are already becoming flavorful
this is when they start to taste like
chocolate during this process
normally i taste the cocoa beans after
they've dried then you can tell if the
harvest and the fermentation process
were good
and that's what matters her artisanal
chocolate business
maya may kakao is trying to make a name
for high quality local chocolate
ortiz sells it online at trade fairs and
other events
and in stores across panama she wants to
change the image of chocolate as just a
sweet treat
instead she sees it as a food packed
with healthy ingredients
these substances are found in the cocoa
pod and if we want to retain the special
qualities of cocoa then we have to eat
it with as little sugar as possible
that's the message i want to spread and
i have the feeling that it's becoming
more and more widely accepted
is not the only chocolate company that
employs natural cultivation methods
and is sparing with its use of sugar
in the last five years several small
panamanian businesses have set
themselves the goal of making healthy
high quality chocolate ortiz herself
enjoys chocolate most when it's liquid
when i drink this cup of hot chocolate i
have the feeling
wow you can taste where the cocoa comes
from the farm that it comes from
the characteristics of each individual
cultivation site
i really savor it i appreciate it i
recognize the potential of the cocoa
produced by
every family
you